david habib et vous avez essuyé les
plâtres d'une nouvelle interview qui
s'appelle l'interview et aux miroirs sur
les biens à monter sur scène
sarsgaard david tu cherchais quelqu'un
qui te ressemblent alors comment ça va
ben écoute ça va bien je suis un peu
fatigué en ce moment parce que bon de
jumbo spaemann et puis je me couche très
tard mais sinon ça va merci de m'avoir
posé cette question t'es content de mon
nouvel album ça c'est genre de questions
que j'aime pas trop répondre
bah écoute ouais ouais ouais je pense
que nani pas mal de temps à le faire
donc je suis content la france non
atteint
ok la france a mis du temps at adopté
mais maintenant ça va
ouais mais ça a toujours été plus ou
moins dans la pas marre qu'on me parle
tout le temps de ton père non j'ai
beaucoup de chance j'adore mon père donc
non j'en ai pas marre non ça va tu pense
qu'il vaut mieux être le fils de johnny
ou de sylvie ça c'est pas évident à
répondre non je suis content d'avoir les
deux le matin quand tu te regarde dans
la glace
est ce que tu te dis ouais cool je suis
david hallyday non non non je me dis pas
ça non je me dis que j'aurais mieux fait
de dormir deux heures de plus
est ce que tu vois un homme heureux en
face de toi a ouais ouais je vois un
homme heureux en face de moi tout à fait
ça fait combien de temps qu'on s'est pas
retrouvée comme ça tous les deux ça doit
faire bien cinq minutes t'as pas envie
de casser ce miroir parfois si ça
m'arrive c'est comme tout le monde
est ce que tu viens pour les vacances
non
et pourquoi tu rigoles patois bien loin
messieurs on leur donne un petit coup
alors comment ça va bah écoute ça va ça
va pas mal tu es content de mon nouvel
album
ben écoute ça s'écoute ça s'écoute pas
mal c'est un peu forcé sur sur la
guitare mais je trouve ça plutôt
sympathique
la france a mis du temps à adopter mais
maintenant
ça va écoute ouais j'ai eu un petit peu
de mal mais quand on arrive des states
j'ai toujours un petit peu difficile
dans s'accoutumer à à la france
t'en a pas marre qu'on ne parle tout le
temps de ton père ben écoute
qu'est ce que tu veux moi j'ai un père
qui est déclarée en douane ça intéresse
tout le monde donc forcément j'écoute
pas dans les émissions as tu pense qu'il
vaut mieux être le fils de johnny ou le
fils de sylvie le fils de johnny mais
pour moi c'est plus facile de répondre
ça le matin quand tu te regarde dans la
glace
est-ce que attend le matin est ce que
quand tu te regardes à glace est ce que
tu te dis que ouais cool je suis days tu
vois c'est pas le matin quand tu te
regarde dans la glace est ce que tu te 2
le matin quand tu te regarde dans la
glace est ce que tu dis cool je suis
joniaux dîner non
on sait que plaire est au sérieux de ce
gros mec francs quand tu te regarde dans
la glace le matin est ce que tu t'es dit
ouais c'est cool d'être david hallyday à
l'époque où j'étais avec estelle est ce
que tu vois en amoureux en face de toi
oui t'as pas envie de casser ce miroir
parfois tu rigoles ou quoi tu sais
combien ça coûte un miroir comme ça est
ce que tu viens pour les vacances
bah ça dépend qui c'est qui paye
alors oui il ressemble à quoi l'homme
que vous voyez dans ce miroir vous en
bas un homme un peu vieillissant mais
encore muse abl ouais tout à fait vous
lui donnez quel âge
- vous le trouver sympathique
oui je trouve sympathique souffre de ma
vie parce que je le connais ouais je
connais le vrai ouais donc je sais que
c'est un type bien
en tout cas qui fait des efforts il est
séduisante ouais on le lui dit souvent
d'après-vous l'homme que vous voyez dans
ce miroir il était beau quand ils
étaient jeunes ils le savaient pas ouais
mais on le lui a prouvé
parfois il est heureux l'homme que vous
voyez dans le miroir lui pas trop
malheureux pour sa vie à lui
ça va s'il a un peu mal au monde
c'est du mal à te regarder là parce que
j'ai une petite érection quand je ne
regarde après vous c'est quoi son métier
à ce mec là bas je le connais c'est oui
mais c'est un au liban c'est un acteur
qui s'est égaré ou musique où il est
et qui peut en effet être aussi acteur
humoriste et peut-être même parfois
écrivain ou l'aimé bien ce mec là le
déteste pas je ne déteste pas c'est à
dire que je suis entouré de gens qui qui
m'aident année mais ouais enfin les met
à le supporter il ya des jours je me
supporte pas je peux toujours d'accord
avec moi ouais temps mais pour nous
qu'est ce qui vous plaît le moins dans
cet homme
cette sorte de 2k far de mélancolie un
peu morbide c'est l'enfance ouais un peu
on guérit jamais de son enfance danon
c'est quoi la différence principale
entre vous et l'homme dans ce miroir
c'est que moi je le regardais 8 pas
ouais si vous le rencontriez pour de
vrai qu'est ce que vous aimeriez lui
dire à cet homme reste encore un peu et
pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
l'inaptitude abonnez vous mettez un
pouce bleus